ich kann nicht mehr
kein Bock mehr
Alter
ich raste aus Mann
der absolute Horror ausgesetzt in der
Wildnis von Schweden kämpft ein Mann
sieben Tage mit sieben Gegenständen ums
Überleben ich bin wieder da der erste
Versuch endete für den outdoor-neuling
schnell ehrlich übelst live Sport und
Helme waren ihm dadurch sicher doch
jetzt ist er zurück an dem Ort an dem
alles begabten Wiedergutmachung keine
Kamerateam Jetzt Geht's Ab kein Kontakt
zur Außenwelt raste aus Mann vollkommene
Isolation
herzlich Willkommen zu Games seven
die heutige Folge wird unterstützt von
Adobe worauf ich wieder einmal
unheimlich stolz bin denn wir nutzen die
Apps von Creative Cloud jeden einzelnen
Tag und mit dem neuen Update launcht
Adobe and feature das nicht nur unseren
sondern den Alltag von vielen kreativen
deutlich vereinfachen kann und das zeige
ich euch jetzt nehmen wir zum Beispiel
das Intro der Serie als erstes brauchen
einen Hintergrund also schreiben wir
dunkle regnerische Waldlandschaft mit C
und Dobby Firefly die neue generative KI
erstellt uns die Landschaft in wenigen
Sekunden passt einfach nichts generieren
wir einfach neue Option als nächstes
brauchen wir Vögel die im Himmel fliegen
ein Floß das im Wasser schwimmt und ein
Bären der aus dem Wald kommt und sogar
mein Outfit können wir beliebig
verändern lassen bis wir den Block haben
den wir brauchen aber genauso gut wie
wir Dinge hinzufügen können können wir
sie auch entfernen beispielsweise stören
uns diese Logos also werde ich sie
einfach aus und lass dich von Firefly
rausrechnen und wenn wir das Ganze dann
noch in after effect animieren bekommen
wir dieses Ergebnis was außerdem mega
gut ist alle generierten Fotos könnt ihr
komplett stressfrei egal ob privat oder
gewerblich nutzen bedeutet ihr müsst
euch also überhaupt keine Gedanken um
Urheberrecht machen die Möglichkeiten
sind wirklich Grenzen unheimlich einfach
anzuwenden und für uns ein absoluter
Traum um unsere Ideen Wirklichkeit
werden zu lassen aktualisiert einfach
jetzt eure Creative Cloud und testet das
Ganze selbst mal aus mehr Informationen
dazu findet ihr unter dem ersten Link
und wenn ihr noch kein Creative Cloud
Abo habt dann checkt den zweiten Link
aus um Adobe Firefly kostenlos in eurem
Browser zu testen völlig egal wofür ich
entscheidet Check die beiden Links
entweder über die Videobeschreibung oder
den angebinden Kommentar um und setzt
eure Ideen in die Wirklichkeit um denn
das was wir euch gezeigt haben ist nur
ein klitze kleiner Teil von dem was
möglich ist vielen Dank an Adobe fürs
möglich machen dieses Videos und euch
viel Spaß mit der vierten Folge meines
Selbstversuchs
so jetzt herzlich Willkommen zu Tag 3
typische Tagesroutine erstens Geschäft
erledigen
und dann
kann ich schon ins Wasser und ich
meine
ich meine
dass das heute
nicht mein letztes Mal im Wasser sein
wird
aber das werden wir sehen wenn wir jetzt
die Challenge aufmachen
so Challenge Tag Nummer 5 heute ist
wieder ganz schlimm mit den Mücken ich
weiß nicht ob das heißt dass wir heute
ein bisschen vor dem Regen bewahrt sind
weil die letzten Tage war quasi gar
nichts mehr los weil sie ganze Zeit
geregnet hat aber jetzt ist wieder alles
voll Challenge Tag Nummer 5 Ei Captain
ich habe es mir schon fast gedacht
baueinfluss das dein Gewicht trägt es
muss mindestens die Maße einmal ein
Meter haben nutze hierbei das Maßband
das ist zu Wasser und Haare 1 Minute
darauf aus ohne unterzugehen das Wasser
muss eine Mindesttiefe von einem Meter
haben du hast Zeit bis die Sonne
untergeht ich habe Paracord
das ist sehr gut ich weiß nicht ob ich
genug Paracord habe ich habe Draht
gestern gefunden
sollte das nicht reichen werde ich
mein Camp etwas umbauen müssen oder
zumindest für kurze Zeit das Paracord
von meinem Camp entfernen müssen ja ich
glaube wir starten einfach direkt weil
ich denke das wird eine Tagesaufgabe so
dann wollen wir mal als erstes könnten
wir uns überlegen wo wir das Ding zu
Wasser lassen wollen
vielleicht vorne bei mir am Strand
wer eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Option
auf der anderen Seite können wir das
einfach dem Holzbestand anpassen und
gucken wo genug Holz ist für uns damit
wir es nicht ewig weit schleppen müssen
gucken wir mal ob wir hier vorne gut ans
Wasser kommen wenn ja
würde ich denken dass das hier schon
unser perfekter Spot ist guck mal da
liegt auch noch Holz da auch noch da
auch noch weil ich glaube ich brauche
richtig viel Holz
und richtig viel Meter Paracord das ist
der Rest den ich habe
vielleicht muss ich den sogar auftrennen
ja das ist natürlich der beschissenste
Spot den man sich vorstellen kann
alles darüber schleppen
an meinen Strand
sie zweite Option so starten wir einfach
mal das hier habe ich gestern schon
geschnitten das hier wird jetzt das
Holzlager fürs los
Nummer eins easy über 1 Meter lang kein
Problem
der nächste
kommt keine Faxen jetzt heute das muss
jetzt sitzen wenig Gegenstände abgegeben
feuerborn nicht anbekommen
es muss es jetzt muss ich muss ich muss
ich
[Applaus]
passt
so mache ich jetzt hier diesen großen
Baum und riskiere dass mir irgendeine
Scheiße auf dem Kopf fällt oder nicht
ich bin schon tempted ja wahrscheinlich
drei Stücke komm ich mach's
bitte
lieber Gott
du hast schon Niklas und feier bestraft
tote Bäume und Seven vs
gab es schon
das ist uns kein zweites Mal machen
[Applaus]
Links
ach du scheiße
Vega
Alter ist das gefährlich
ich sehe die ganze Zeit nur noch
Blaubeer
Essen ich bin nicht
fertig diese Nacht war jetzt auch um
ehrlich zu sein nicht so mega geil
zum ersten Mal ich konnte nicht pennen
ja
Punkt
[Musik]
den Rest muss ich aus stemmen machen die
irgendwo liegen ich kann nicht noch so
ein Baum um machen Alter das kostet so
viel Energie ich will jetzt 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 glaube ich
vielleicht reicht das ja sogar schon
so jetzt schauen wir mal
die sind halt trocken die sind gar nicht
so schwer die kriege ich wahrscheinlich
sogar so zwei von denen nicht ganz so
fetten kriege ich wahrscheinlich sogar
auf eins gepackt
muss ich mir erstmal überlegen
aus welchen Stämmen ich das Konstrukt
bauen will vielleicht
aus den beiden langen
und den beiden kurzen
der so
und der so
so
das wäre doch ein absolutes
traumszenario
Kerben machen mit dem Messer
stellen wir da rein
weitersehen
Alter das passt wie angegossen
ja ja ja ja ja ja
oh ja oh ja oh ja Alter das sieht nach
einem richtigen floß aus
das hier
ist die eine Seite
die ich festgemacht habe oder die ich
benutzt habe um das Ding fest zu ziehen
die kann ich jetzt ja eigentlich einfach
hier rum ziehen hier
festmachen
jetzt mit ordentlich Zug
rein
rein Alter wenn das so einfach
funktionieren würde
dann fresse ich wirklich einen
Besenstiel
schön in der Mitte ziehen
okay
so hält das jetzt schon mal
ganz okay zusammen
eins
schöne Gewichtsverteilung hier
zwei
bitte nicht direkt wegschwimmen ich muss
es liegend machen
über alle Äste hinweg
bleibt alle bei mir meine Äste
ihr müsst alle bei mir bleiben
ich bin so desperate diese Punkte zu
bekommen
die Fackel war gut
Gegenstände abgeben habe ich mich nicht
getraut nur Klamotten abgegeben
hat verfickte Scheiße noch mal nicht
funktioniert
dieses scheiß Floß muss jetzt
funktionieren
ja ja ja
ja ja
hier den auch noch unter meinen Arsch
okay
wir stechen den See
es geht
[Musik]
das war's
wir müssen gemeinsam entscheiden
ob das jetzt die Punkte gibt oder nicht
ich war für eine Minute auf dem Floß auf
dem Wasser
mit einem Meter
das war die Metrik
und ich musste nicht paddeln immer über
der Wasseroberfläche zu bleiben das Ding
ist geschwommen ich konnte nicht sitzen
ich konnte nicht stehen
ohne das Wasser zu berühren aber ich war
am Schwimmen
Challenge ist ja nicht bauen floss mit
dem du dich sicher genug fühlen würdest
den Atlantik zu überqueren ne
komm wenn ich jetzt eh schon nass bin
dann gibt es die
zweite duscheinheit für heute
was soll ich machen
Schluck trinken kann ich auch direkt
das ist doch besser geht's doch nicht
Tag 5 fast durch Tag 6 Tag 7 schlafen
fertig dreimal schlafen zwei Tage besser
geht's wirklich nicht
schaut euch das mal an
so viel Zeit habe ich ich stehe hier am
Sumpf weil die Sonne hier gerade noch so
schön rein knallt und Wedel meine
Boxershorts so hin und her dass da
möglichst viel Luft dran kommt
und die möglichst schnell trocknet ob
das was bringt keine Ahnung aber ich
habe ja eh nichts zu tun also ich kann
eh nichts machen
[Musik]
ich habe zwar keinen angelequipment aber
jetzt komme ich doch noch dazu
die wird jetzt schön gebacken von allen
Seiten
wunderbar im besten baue ich mir jetzt
noch irgendeine Halterung dass die hier
so stehen kann
je nachdem wie nie richtig das Ding
hänge
das hätte so eine perfekte Angel sein
können
naja richtig schön ist ehrliches Feuer
am Ende vom Tag 5 ich habe einfach
keinen Hunger
ich
esse Blaubeeren und ich suche mir Hände
voll
aber das ist einfach aus irgendeinem
Grund war das Tag 1 Tag 2 war das ein
riesen Thema für mich und ich dachte oh
nein ich muss unbedingt was essen Tag 3
bisschen weniger Tag 4 schon nichts mehr
da Tag 5
das fühlt sich an als bräuchte ich das
nicht mehr das ist mega komisch also
umso besser wenn das die nächsten Tage
so bleibt ich hoffe nicht dass ich
irgendwie
zurückverfalle in die denke dass ich
jeden Moment sterbe wenn ich nicht mehr
jetzt
keine Ahnung was ein Barsch reinziehe
aber essen ist kein Thema die Situation
ist so ich habe zwar vielleicht keinen
Bock unbedingt oder ich wünsche mich
nach Hause oder ich wünsche mich zu
meinen Freunden oder ich wünsche mich zu
was zu essen oder ich wünsche mich in
meinem Bett aber es ist völlige
Akzeptanz ich bin auf einem richtigen ja
wie so ein runners high
ich habe das Ziel vor Augen zwei Tage
noch drei Nächte
habt ihr das gehört die Mücken egal wie
viel Feuer ich mache sie sind da
guten Morgen
Tag Nummer 6
öffne meinen Tag wir schauen in die
Challenge und dann startet der vorletzte
Tag
yes
Tag Nummer 6
ist alles voll mit Mücken
kein Regen das ist gut dafür alles voll
mit Mücken
und seit Tagen meine Haare nicht
gewaschen meine Zähne auch nicht geputzt
muss ich mich vielleicht auch mal drum
kümmern
du bist nicht du wenn du hungrig bist
perfekt suche alternative
Nahrungsquellen in Form von Insekten
oder Würmern jedes Tier muss mindestens
1 cm groß sein nutzt zu Überprüfung das
Maßband jedes jeder gegessene Snack
ergibt ein Punkt bis zu einer maximalen
Anzahl von 7 Punkten da fährst du Zeit
bis die Sonne untergeht
easy peasy
stimmt nicht überhaupt nicht easy peasy
hier gibt es nämlich quasi keine
Insekten
die Leute erinnern sich vielleicht an
Martins verzweifelte Suche nach Würmern
in Staffel 1 ich habe das in meiner Zeit
wo ich nicht ausgesetzt war sondern im
Camper auch mal versucht und hier gibt's
mega wenig aber mit genug Zeit sollte
das schon klappen als allererstes mache
ich aber Feuer an um die Mücken
irgendwie loszuwerden vielleicht sind
die ja auch schon über 1 cm dann kann
ich mir eine packen und essen
heute versuche ich mal ein bisschen mehr
Hygiene an den Tag zu legen nämlich hier
Kohle mit und probiere mir die Zähne zu
putzen
[Musik]
vielleicht benutze ich doch lieber
einfach meinen Shirt
und putze mir damit die Zellen boah
Alter
wollen wir richtig schwarz vor Augen
beim Aufstehen Alter
sieht gut aus
schaut mal hier während ich gerade mich
vor dem Regen geschützt habe wo man
sieht es nicht so auf der Kamera aber
die Beine von dieser Mücke
kann man das erkennen die Beine von der
Mücke gehen noch über das Maßband hinaus
bis auf einen Zentimeter
ich nehme das als erstes Insekt über 1
cm
hmm
lecker
kann man die Insekten kommen zu mir ich
muss sie nicht mal selber suchen
wunderbar
Alter die ist aber garantiert über 1 cm
seht ihr das wie die Fühler danach oben
weggehen
dann ist das an bis hier geht er eine
Fühler und bis da ist wieder über ein
Zentimeter sieht man das das stellt
nicht scharf die Beine sind zwar die das
über 1 cm groß sein lassen
aber es ist so
hier
kann man das Erkennen Nummer zwei
wunderbar
ich habe mir was abgemessen
sieht man jetzt nicht ein bisschen
verschwindet unter meinem Handschuh aber
das genau ein Zentimeter
jetzt suchen wir Bäume die tot sind
dieses Ding ist aber mal ganz easy in
Zentimeter das sind eher zwei
Alter
gerade hier gefunden habe diese Dinger
gesehen dachte so hey wie komisch wenn
man da rein sticht
kommt wie so Farbe raus
was ist das das sieht aus wie Paintball
Kugeln
krass keine Ahnung was es sein soll bei
der Farbe aber vermutlich giftig und
auch wenn ich das jetzt schon wirklich
oft gesehen habe und in den letzten
Tagen auch nur das gesehen habe
ist das immer wieder geil meine Insel
wir haben Frieden geschlossen
zwei Nächte anderthalb Tage heute noch
durch dann pennen Morgen durch dann
pennen dann komplett durch unglaublich
und ich hoffe hoffe hoffe hoffe hoffe
mit allem was ich habe ich drücke alle
Daumen dass ich nicht als Ersatzkandidat
in der dritten Staffel einspringen muss
ich habe gar keinen Bock jetzt noch mal
innerhalb der nächsten Wochen für 14
Tage
noch mal woanders mit Bären draußen zu
sein hiermit konnte ich mich jetzt
wirklich gut anfreunden über die letzten
Tage aber noch mal doppelte Länge kein
Bock wirklich überhaupt kein Bock
die Zeit wird nicht rumgehen die geht
jetzt schon nicht rum aber 14 Tage schon
mal vor dann wäre ich jetzt am Tag sechs
dann wären noch acht die kommen würden
so ein Mücken Vieh auch safen Zentimeter
mit mir auch gestochen hat
wunderbar
vier
zwischendrin Geschmack neutralisieren
also mein Körper ist so runtergefahren
aus irgendeinem Grund habe ich nach wie
vor nicht so richtigen Hunger ich habe
übelst Appetit aber
mein Magen knurrt nicht wie es
normalerweise ist wenn ich nur
acht Stunden nichts gegessen habe
nein
da
ich habe es tatsächlich mit zwei Fingern
gecatcht
schaut euch das an
Alter ich hoffe man hat das auf der
Kamera gesehen
gut man muss die Flügel ausklappen damit
es ein Zentimeter ist aber dann
schmeckt nach gar nichts
wieder ein paar Blaubeeren hinterher
zerfressen von irgendwas
was ich bewegt
wieder nichts also jetzt zum Abend hier
in der Dämmerung ist das wirklich kaum
auszuhalten mit dem ganzen Fliege viel
ihr seht das alles nicht die sind so
winzig kleinen aber die Fakten so krank
ab nur deswegen mache ich Feuer
boah Alter das hält man wirklich nicht
aus
boah
scheiße
das ist ja so fies
wirklich der einzige Grund warum ich das
hier mache
boah das hält man wirklich nicht aus
aber schaut euch das mal an
diese Idylle
aber klar das ist perfekt ist Mücken
Wetter
Tag zu Ende Alter ich glaube es nicht
ich kann es wirklich nicht glauben
endlich geht die Scheiße vorbei
oh mein Gott
fünf Nächte schon
sechs Tage perfekt Stand gehalten Setup
von Tag eins nicht mehr nachgespannt gar
nichts gemacht alles bestens
richtig krass
[Musik]
das Feuer bis zum Ende genossen ihr seht
mich wahrscheinlich nicht aber jetzt
geht es in Nacht Nummer 6
bedeutet die vorletzte Nacht
[Musik]
ich habe komplett damit abgeschlossen
ich habe es genossen ich habe es gehasst
ich habe was gelernt ich kann nicht mehr
und ich will nicht mehr
alles ist in dich Nebel gehüllt
[Musik]